how are you doing today sir
hey good steve yourself i'm doing
excellent uh
i just did an hour-long interview with
frank grillo a few days ago
and he told me specifically to tell you
that he says hi
thank you so much thank you until frank
you said that
um uh i know that listen i know that
you're offered a number of scripts um
and a number of projects i'm curious
what was it about this one that says
i want to do this one there was
something
i don't want to use the expression
old-fashioned about it there was just
something
of a loner a rancher
who has you know defended his country as
a marine
and his hit is falling on hard times
and you know when that happens most of
us
if we've gone through that we tend to
shut ourselves off
close off and this guy with this
kid that he's going to try and help just
opens him up and it's uh it's just a
very
human story about connecting
and uh and he my guy
learns so much from this kid if he's uh
you know i don't want to give a spoiler
alert but when he's
taken this kid to his the destination
that his mother wanted him to go to
it uh it just opens this man up
and he hasn't been open since his wife
died that he was
madly in love with a few years ago when
he passed away
and he's learned from it he's done
something good
in his life you know at this point uh in
your career you've done so many
different roles
is there something that you're still
looking for or a type of
a genre or a role that you're still
itching to play
um no not not in any particular genre
but uh i do admire writing and writers
you know people like scott frank who's a
phenomenal writer
i had the pleasure of working with a few
years ago um
you know i don't know if you saw the
queen's gambit
yeah i mean i was that just knocked me
all right this is
this is the same writer who directed a
wonderful show with jeff daniels western
godless godless thank you it was
michelle dockery i thought it was superb
i mean this
um so anyway i'm i uh
you know it if it's on the page it'll be
on the stage
you know i i just admire writers
so much no matter what the genre is if
it moves me in some way
when i read the script down i'll try and
do it
when i put on twitter that i was going
to talk to you uh one
i got a million tweets of people talking
about star wars and asking him about
star wars
are you a little surprised at the fans
still wanting you to return to play
qui-gon in some way
i i'll be honest with you i haven't
heard that at all
oh i i've definitely heard it okay
um sure i'd like to i mean i'm
i'm wondering if star wars starting to
fade away from the
cinema landscape do we think actually
disney plus is launching like 10 series
that are based on star wars and one of
them is
an obi-wan series with you and mcgregor
okay
they're sort of spin-offs are they yeah
it's gonna it's gonna take place
see i was wondering if ewing had called
you and said um
hey i'm doing a spin-off series maybe we
can do like a flashback
sure i'd be up for that yeah i hope you
get to return
i loved your work in star wars and i
love your work and everything thank you
so much for your time
thank you mike i appreciate it thank you